baby
this western
he likes to be the leader
everybody
have your own lifestyle
goodbye
and they made a change
and it seems to me you lived your life
but i was just
is when you die
for the press still hounded to you all
the papers had to say
was that maryland was found in the news
legendary
hold yourself
but i will just be
you can go burned up
so
i pray you'll be armed
and much
in times when we don't know
let this
lead us to
to place
i prayed
please please please
please
baby you did me wrong
please please
i
oh
baby take my hands
please
i love your souls
i paid my dues
time after time
i've done my sentence
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
and we'll keep on
we are the champions
yes
you brought me
no pleasure crew
i consider it a
my
challenge
oh
my friends
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
the 45th president of the united states
of america
donald j trump
next to you and
cause then ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the usa
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and save
is
and
still today
wow this is our big crowd
this is one hell of a big crowd
well i want to thank everybody thank you
gastonia
gastonia thank you to gastonia
beautiful day 13 days can you believe it
13 days from now and you see what's
going on
you see oh they're getting a little
nervous over there you know
the deep state the democrats
all of these people that we've been
dealing with they're getting a little
bit nervous aren't they huh
we're going to win this state 13
this days great state
and we're going to win four more years
in the white house
with your vote we will continue to cut
taxes
cut regulations lower drug prices like
never before support
our great police and law enforcement
protect your incredible second amendment
defend our borders maintain energy
independence
and ensure more products are proudly
stamped
with the phrase made in the usa
and it's happening now we will deliver
record prosperity
epic job growth a very safe vaccine
that's coming very quickly
that pandemic is surrounding the corner
they hate it when i say it you know you
turn on to this
msdnc and fake new cnn all you hear is
kovind
kovit kovetkovakovic overcome
coleman covent covent coleman that's all
they put on because they want to scare
the hell out of everyone
and you know the more testing you have
the more cases they say cases are up
yeah testing is up we have more testing
than
india china and almost every other
country put together
you could say it's ridiculous at the
same time we did a good job but it shows
a lot of cases
and yes thank you he's a great job we
did do a great job
normal life will fully resume and next
year
will be the greatest economic year
in the history of our country that's
where we're at
this election is a choice between a
trump
super recovery or abiding steep
depression and that's what you're going
to have
it's between a trump boom or a biden
lockdown he wants to lock you down you
know
by the way by the way i love this state
you got to get your governor to open up
your state
here gotta get him to open up
open up your state governor it's time
you've been long enough
watch november 4th north carolina we're
opening up
november 4th you know they're only doing
this for political reasons many many
states big big
powerful states they're open they're
doing great
but your governor doesn't want to and
you look at miss michigan now
michigan we won in the supreme court she
had no constitutional right to do what
she did
the only one that had freedom in
michigan was her husband he had plenty
of freedom
he went swinging and he went voting
whenever he wanted biden will delay
therapies postpone the vaccine
prolong the pandemic close your schools
and shut down our country and that's
what he'll do
he will massively raise your taxes he
won't even know he's doing it by the way
but let's go into it
he has no clue but that's all right bury
you in regulations dismantle your police
departments dissolve our borders
confiscate your guns that would be
happening very quickly
eliminate private health care 180
million
people private health care they love it
they want to eliminate it
they want to go to socialized medicine
you too can go to a hospital ward and
see how your cold is coming along wait
for four or five days before you get in
terminate
religious liberty destroy the suburbs
and slash defense spending
devastating north carolina's incredible
military families by the way
we've invested more in the military in
the last three years than at any time
in our nation's history all made in the
usa
joe biden has made a corrupt bargain in
exchange for his party's nomination
which he should have never gotten
if pocahontas got out two days early
instead of
what she did to crazy bernie was
unbelievable because they split up the
crazy vote
and that vote doesn't like kim very much
i don't know you know they're not doing
so well
you know people like aren't showing up i
shouldn't say this is too early right
oh there they are 61.
from north carolina some of the great
women of the world
61 times oh oh look at you
and you have your husbands with you
tonight look at you
look at you
good now i asked him last time how many
times have you gone
61 thank you thank you
i love you too
all right so don't explain thank you
that's so nice i said the other night
you make me cry
and you know what one of these fake
anchors said donald trump
started crying during a speech
i think that's a bad thing in fact it
would probably good maybe it would be
good if i did you know some people say
hey why don't you do that every once in
a while i wouldn't be so bad
now the other thing they said fake fake
people
i joke and i say women of the suburbs
please
please love me i've done so good now
i've done so good i've done so good for
you
please just like this you know we're
kidding i mean i'm being suck
please but i mean it because i'm saving
your suburbs i'm going to stop
low income housing i'm going to stop
projects and we're going to stop crime
from going into the suburbs
so i mean but i said i said
jokingly the last time out last time out
i said
women of the suburbs please please
love me i've done such a good job please
no
and on 60 minutes take 60 minutes
she said you are begging for women to
love you
you said women please love you
you'll see you'll see where do you see
we have a little
surprise for 60 minutes
no it's not no it's true
i won't name the anchor do you know the
anchor
so no she said
well you you were begging for women to
love you i said no no
that was sarcastic that was remember i
said russia russia russia if you're
listening
please give us whatever it was hillary's
emails order
and then everybody laughed and i left
but they kept me off just before they
and they said he was asking russia for
help these people are sick
shifty shift and all that group they are
sick
so you see from now on when i say women
of the suburbs
please love you i'm gonna have to say
i'm only kidding i'm only kidding
because otherwise
but they'll take that out too sleepy joe
biden has handed control of his party
over to socialist communist
marxists and left-wing extremists
and they're filled with hatred venom and
rage
the first thing washington democrats
will do
if sleepy joe is elected is go to sleep
i guess
you know i had a leader that called me a
really dynamic leader called me up about
two weeks ago i said
i don't want to deal with him he's
always going to be sleeping can you
imagine it
the word gets around but the first thing
washington democrats will do if biden
gets elected
is pack the supreme court with radical
left judges
who will eliminate your second amendment
and many other things life
life look at the things they have to
rule on they will pack it
somebody said sixteen i said why not
eighteen why not twenty one at twenty
two
and he's gotta also tell us who the
judges are he won't tell he won't talk
because if he does
he's gonna totally lose the radical left
so he won't say
he's in his basement you're right about
that
no i go through these interviews every
question is a total kill
right every question they're going for
the kill and this guy walks out holding
ice cream
and the press is out there the fake news
and this guy
what kind of ice cream are you eating ah
chocolate i think in vanilla too
i say why don't they ever ask me those
questions right they don't ask me those
questions
if biden wins the flag burning
demonstrators on the street
will be running your federal government
don't worry it's not going to happen it
can't happen
you know my statement our country
will never be a socialist country
they'll decide which businesses can
exist
and which will be outlawed they will
decide which rights you can keep
and which are going to be revoked they
will
re-educate your children which they
tried and we stopped
but they will do it you saw what i did
with the people that wanted to sort of
do a culture change right they were all
gone out of our military they've gone
out of everything
but they'll re-emerge if you have the
wrong leader they'll
they'll re-emerge quickly they'll order
you to stay at home
while letting riders and ms-13 killers
roam free without masks
without masks ms-13 doesn't have to wear
a mask
you ever see that they riot they loot
they do everything no problem
you get together you get together that's
why we have
outdoors we always go outdoors right
but they have a thing you can't do
anything you can't go to church
right you can't go to church
your kids can't go to school even so
it's 99.9
99.9 in fact you know baron had it
sir he just tested positive who baron
oh like about 12 seconds later how's he
doing oh he's recovered oh good thank
you
let's face it they have stronger immune
systems
stronger immune they're very powerful i
never realized how powerful children
are they will censor you punish you and
persecute you
for violating their speech codes and
oppressive mandates you've seen it
you've been saying what's going on
but you know what we've got the white
house we're winning that's it
as long as we have them
and we're knocking them out left and
right
i wonder what's going to happen we win
they announce ladies and gentlemen
donald trump has won the presidency of
the united states
i think they'll be very happy they're
going to be very happy no they'll be
upset
and then they'll be just fine right
they'll be just fine they'll be very
thrilled
they'll be thrilled
i'll tell you this i'll tell you this
you know i don't wanna i love this
particular state but i might not have
come here so often i've been all over
your state you better let me win
i mean i mean
laura and eric we had a beautiful they
had a beautiful daughter granddaughter
for me
and they named the granddaughter
carolina
now when i go to south carolina i can
also give them some credit right
right now
it's uh it's great it's a great place if
you want your children to grow up in a
free nation where they can speak their
minds and practice their religion
and live by their values then you must
defeat
sleepy joe biden and the radical left
reject left wing fascism
vote for american freedom vote for
america first vote for make america
great again
what i was thinking i was thinking on
the plane down i just put this in
i don't know i just and i said to myself
and i said to a group
small group on the plane the great mark
meadows is here do you know mark
i had to go all the way to north
carolina
to find a guy's doing a good job i don't
know where the hell he is he's always
working
he's back there someplace where is he
oh there oh look at come up mark come on
i'll tell you he has done a really great
job look at him
central casting too central
he loves his state i will tell you that
it took me three years to get him out of
congress and
we have another great friend of ours
here mick mulvaney he's really been
great
mick he's a south carolina
and he's a good man too and we have some
other warriors here we have some of your
congressmen and some others so we'll
introduce them later the hell with the
bullet judicium layer
just think of it i said this to them
just a little while ago
i shouldn't say it's sad because they're
going to say he was extremely sad
but it is sad but just think of it i
said
i'm all by myself and i've had to beat
the fake news lame stream media
and their partner the democrat party
and now we find out without any doubt
we've had to beat the big tech giants
and add to that we've had to beat
the really stupid dumb people the never
trumpers
we've had to beat the rhinos that's
republican in name only rhino i love
that terror
got a lot around it's got more runners
than we should
and we had to beat the pundits and the
consultants that i've soundly defeated
almost every single one of these clowns
you know they all represented somebody
don't forget we had 17 people running in
the primers and just about every one of
these clowns represented somebody
and i defeated them so badly that
they've never gotten over it they do
commercials they do
these people are sick they're sick
they're sad sad people
and on top of everything else
we've had a soundly defeat we're in the
process of doing it it's much deeper
than i thought
the deep staters right we had a being of
mistipo you know the swamp
and the swamp creatures are much deeper
and much worse than we ever thought
and there is such a thing as the deep
state who
but you know with all of those people
it's a lot and i stand here by myself
and then i said to the people in the
plane wonderful beautiful
it's got more television sets than any
plane in history
i saw you i saw this massive look at the
size of this crowd they're never going
to report that they never talk about it
you know
they never talk about it
they never talk about crowds you
remember when we had the inauguration i
said we had the biggest crowd
and then they show empty space and they
show barack hussein obama's craft
and i said i said why didn't we i think
the word we used was audience that it
included all of the new things you know
the all of the different things that we
have coming out every week there's a new
form of
information coming out so i think we had
the largest audience anywhere in the
world
but they showed this field now when i
was speaking it was full
but when they show the field it was all
empty i said wait a minute i was
speaking it was full
well they took the pictures about five
or six hours early
they had everything roped off and you
know i said to my people we're gonna
sort of bring that up everyone so oh sir
nobody cares about i care about it
i care about it no they took the
pictures
way early and what i was speaking i'm
looking at this thing all the way back
it was so beautiful
and then all of a sudden we made the
statement i guess the largest audience
and i think it was the largest audience
and we suffered that was the first week
this was just the beginning
this was just the beginning but when i
was speaking it was packed
just like this place is packed look at
that into the hangar
it's a lot of people
but i had it again too i had a guy i
think his name was wiggle wiggle wiggle
from the washington post he goes to an
arena
and all of the arenas were packed now
we're doing outdoor
because of coverage sometimes referred
to as the china virus right
which i think is afar which i think is a
far more accurate
i mean you could also use the corona
word but that sounds like a beautiful
town in italy it's not fair
no this is the china plague or the china
virus that's where it came from
we have to be accurate and we were
really doing well against china we still
are by the way but we were doing so well
you know hey do you remember that for
years for 10 years you heard china was
going to
supplant us in 2019 right 2019 they were
going to be bigger than us their economy
well
that didn't work out too well for them
we were beating them by leaps and bounds
and then we got hit with the flag
no sooner had the ink dried on a great
china deal we made a wonderful tre you
know
it was great in fact they ordered the
largest amount two weeks ago corn
soy beans and beef cattle
beef that we've ever had because they
want to keep me happy because they know
i'm not
i'm not satisfied this is no good what
happened this is no good what they did
to us
no good the ink hadn't even dried on our
trade deal with china
wonderful deal and this happened this
should have been stopped to china they
should have been able to stop it
they stopped it from going into the rest
of china but they didn't stop it from
going into europe the united states and
the rest of the world right
we're going to find out why too but the
american people are with me so
i stand alone and i said to these people
i apologize you mind if i said i
instead of we because it is a group of
very loyal people
i said plays much better when i say hi
but we do have a great group of people
but we do we're standing sort of alone
against all of these people
you mean i mean i saw adam shift this
guy the watermelon head i say
no he's like a watermelon head yep no
dummy
no dummy and he doesn't believe it but
he said the other day
about biden with the laptop from hell
we call it the leopard he said and and
he goes up
before the mic this is adam shifty chef
this was caused by russia
russia russia caused this
they created this disinformation he said
right he should be honestly that guy
should be locked up
and you know because he's in congress
oh it's true you know because he's
remember when he said i had this perfect
phone call with the president of ukraine
i'm the only one that could get
impeached over a phone call that was
perfect
remember shifty shift got up then he
started repeating it
eight times quid pro quo and you will
send you will that
and you will listen fortunately we had
beautiful transcribers that transcribed
the call
can you imagine if we didn't have it
would have been my word about against
shifty schiff
and all of the horrible human beings
over there
they died when they found out we had a
transcription remember
they wanted to know how do we get out of
this one so we had to beat that one off
too but that was
a little bit lucky thank you to your
wonderful transcribers you did a great
job but you know
this is what we're dealing we're dealing
with some tough people
and evil people somebody said president
a friend of mine from new york very
successful guy big builder
said president president you know they
don't call me donald anymore i lost all
my friends because everybody
they call me up they say oh it's the
president and it's the president i pick
him
hey richard how you doing rich hey guys
mr president sir how are you
he used to say hey don how about going
out to dinner tonight
it's true i lost all my friends because
they all respect the office
forget about they respect the office of
the president
and he'll call me up he'll say uh mr
president
sir i've known this guy for so many
years i don't see exactly how many but
too many many let's put it this way many
more than 30.
so i say richard listen up listen up yes
sir i say call me donald yes sir okay
so we're going on and i say how's
everything going how's new york i miss
it
it's going to hell with this crazy mayor
and this crazy governor we have
crime is through the rule crime in new
york is through the roof
and it all happened since i left i mean
maybe i should take credit for that
that we did a good job no but it's very
sad what happened
i said how's it going we talk and then
he ends it by saying mr president sir
thank you very much
mr richard you have to thank me for
speaking to me and it's one of those
things
but they have respect for the office
right they have respect
for the office and we have to have more
respect for our country
when somebody gets up before the halls
of congress in the halls
so when schiff gave this phony speech
about my conversation
he was quoting my conversation he didn't
know we had it transcribed
and normally i wouldn't do that we
actually called up ukraine we said do
you mind if we release it
they said no they didn't understand why
but they were nice
you know they were very nice i said do
you mind no
we had our secretary of state call
actually do you mind because it would be
nice to let them know we're going to
release it right
would be very nice and what happens is
it was totally different
and i said oh we're going to sue him and
we're going to do things to him because
he lied in the halls of congress
and they told me you know what they told
me no sir i'm sorry
he has total immunity he can say
anything he wants
in the hospital that's wrong
and i thought to myself isn't that crazy
it should be the exact opposite
you should be mandated to be more honest
in the halls of congress
not where you have immunity to say
anything you want
oh did they die did nancy did crazy
nancy go crazy when she heard that we
had
a transfer she looked at her people she
said what the hell is this this is not
impeachable
they say you're right but we're so far
down the road let's go for it anyway
this is what we're dealing with
and we won it's good to win though i
have to tell you willingness
great republican support we had great
republican support
in the house it was 196 or so to nothing
and we got a democrat and a half
andrew good guy running for office going
to do very well jeff he's going to do
very well he came over he said
this is so corrupt i'm going to become a
republican
and
and he's going to do great but it really
is think of it when you're in the halls
of congress you should be more honest
instead of where you can say anything
you want
that's probably maybe we should go for
it let's go for a little change
the radical biden harris agenda
is projected to slash the typical
american
home income by at least six thousand
five hundred dollars per year think of
that they'll raise your taxes
by four you know biden's gonna raise
your taxes we can go four trillion
everyone says what does that mean
you know what it means it means a lot
they're gonna raise your taxes by four
trillion dollars triggering a mass
exodus of jobs out of america into
foreign countries you know how many jobs
i brought in
i brought in jobs that would just stifle
because our taxes were so crazy
the biden tax hikes will wipe out up to
another quarter of the small business
income
and 25 of all u.s investment your stocks
your 401ks and pensions will be
demolished
you'll go into a depression the likes of
which you haven't seen
since 1929. that's what's going to
happen
going to raise your taxes he's going to
put all the regulations back on
i'm sure he'll join the wonderful paris
accord how's it working out for france i
don't think so right
no it takes away our wealth it was meant
to take away our wealth somebody will
come in someday
and they'll say isn't that wonderful our
air
is cleaner than all of them we just had
our best
numbers environmentally cleanest
the best without spending
fortunes and it's rigged for china and
russia
and india and all these other countries
and it's really bad for us
and everybody said you know when i did
that when i got out of the paris
climate accord okay they call it the
paris
when i got out such a beautiful name
right when i got out the people
understood it immediately i think i said
this is a tough one i'm gonna get killed
in this one that's okay close your eyes
sign it bomb
but the people got it right away they're
taking your wealth away
they don't want oil they don't want
petroleum
they don't want you know why because
they don't have it and because we do we
are the number one in the world right
now and they want to take it away
biden's plan will destroy 5 million jobs
eliminate 2.6 trillion dollars in wealth
and hurt lower and middle-income
families the most of all
i will deliver optimism opportunity and
hope biden will deliver pessimism
poverty and
decline for the last 47 years joe biden
has been outsourcing your job opening
your borders
oh by the way our border is closed
that's why you never hear about it do
you ever notice you don't hear about
that
you don't hear about our vets anymore
because we take such good remember every
night you hear about vets
before me 91 approval
rating with our vets our vets voted 91
we never had anything like it
and sacrificing american blood and
treasure
in endless foreign wars in countries
that you've never even heard of
and they're all coming back you know
that right i mean i hope anybody
i hope nobody objects i think 19 years
in afghanistan is enough wouldn't you
say we're like a police force over there
we have the greatest soldiers in the
world but over there we're like a police
force
19 years isn't if you think it's easy
getting out with all the
military industrial complex right dwight
eisenhower the military beware the
military industrial complex they're
right
but we're all coming home they're all
coming home
in 2016 north carolina voted to fire
this
depraved political establishment and you
elected an
outsider as president who is finally
putting
america first
joe biden as you've been reading for the
last
four weeks although it's hard to find
because they shut it that
you've learned how corrupt the press is
more than what i've been saying for four
years
i've known it i've said it but i don't
know how many people believed it
you see how corrupt they are when the
new york times and the washington post
and all of these other
they don't even write about a man who is
a totally
corrupt politician he's a corrupt
politician
in addition he led communist china
plunder your jobs while his family
raked in millions from china and foreign
nations think of it
how about russia how about russia
three and a half million dollars from
the mayor of moscow's wife three and a
half oh i see what did you do for that
there's a lot that's like one of the
smaller hits
he was like a vacuum cleaner you know
they go into a country it was like
having a vacuum cleaner just suck it all
in and if you mention it it's if you
mention it
and i take i have great respect for the
new york post the new york house fourth
largest newspaper the oldest
is but the new york post what they've
done is incredible
but you know the big tech they put you
out
twitter they take you out charlie kirk
so many people
they take them out they take them out
they say we're not going to stand for
this
if you call them corrupt they'll say
we're not going to stand because
that's where they're coming from think
of what's happening
nobody thought does everyone know what
i'm talking about nobody thought it was
even possible
and the newspaper are news you know all
the news that's fit to print
actually it's all the news it's not fit
to print because they don't want to
print it
they don't want to put it in i mean it
is disgraceful
we talk about freedom of the press this
is the exact opposite
of freedom of the press they don't want
to put the word out
and even me i make a speech like this
they'll turn off look i bet you the
cameras turn off because they don't want
it
nobody even me i'm the big cynic of the
world i never thought this was possible
his so-called biden center at the
university of pennsylvania
has already received 70 million dollars
from
china 70 million that can't be possible
is that possible
explosive emails from hunter biden also
show that hunter was negotiating with a
chinese firm
tied to the communist china party to
receive
10 million dollars a year for
introductions well that sounds
reasonable i think you'd do that
i think i'd even do it 10 million to
introduce hey i'd like to introduce it
send me the 10 million
another email referenced 10 percent
held by hunter for the big guy i wonder
who the big guy was the big guy
he doesn't look so big to me he doesn't
look so big when he walks on the stage
he's not looking too strong
fragile very fragile but the big guy
they call him the big guy
one document shows a plan to take money
from chinese state-owned enterprises
this i'll tell you what this laptop is
disaster
how the hell did he ever let go of this
sucker
he put it to a he got to have it fixed i
guess he forgot to pick it up
what the hell and then shift that's
where he played
he said it's russia did it it's russia
russia oh russia they probably think we
are the wackiest people
what do we do now he created a laptop
for hunter bike with pictures and all
this is a matter of national security
the bidens got rich well
north carolina and our country got
robbed okay
if biden wins china will own
the united states
the media and the big tech are
desperately trying to cover up this
massive scandal i'm not
just running against sleepy joe biden
i'm running against the corrupt media
they're corrupt the corrupt media
the big tech giants and i'm running
against the washington swamp
it's time to send a message to these
wealthy
liberal hypocrites by delivering
joe biden a thundering defeat on
november 3rd
that's a lot of people this is a big
crowd
by the way this is a big crowd you
should have seen the people on the road
they couldn't get in you know as big as
this crowd is
tens of thousands of people on the roads
coming up
they said how big is your arena i said i
don't know we have a big field
oh good i said it sold out how do you
sell out a field
i said sir i'm sorry we can't let anyone
else in the police they're great by the
way
i said officer we have 10 000 people out
there much more than that all the way
down
he said i'm sorry sir i said it's a
field just let's open it up let's move
the trucks back the puzzle everything
they said sir we have a problem what
stampede i said stamp
he said we got so many people we're
worried about it i thought that was for
cattle right he said stampy
now can you imagine now joe doesn't have
that problem he has about four or five
circles
he can't fill him up i love the people
the only thing i like about him is the
person that does the circles after this
is all over
no they do a beautiful job nice wide
beautiful everything
you know i'm a perfectionist it's
beautiful those circles they're very far
away from each other
you couldn't catch covet in those
circles no matter what you do
so if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician it's because i'm
not a politician
thank you
the only thing we do to make them
totally crazy
is we say 12 more years because you're
dressing
right then they say see he is a fascist
ah they've covered me they've covered me
every way they've said
he is so stupid then they say
he's not really smart then they say he's
trying to take over the entire
country then they say no no no no
no no he's a super genius he's more
brilliant than every greatest ever
he's trying to take over the entire
world so i go from not being smart to
being the smartest person in history
but evil someday they're going to say
you know what he was a smart guy ran a
great country okay that's what we want
it's this country
no they've had everything they've called
me everything in the book
they've called me names that you
wouldn't believe
and we just keep going along right
because
nobody's been able to do what we've done
in the first three and a half years
nobody even close
so if i don't always play by the rules
of the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you harder than anybody has ever fought
for you before
nobody's ever fought for you you think
this is easy
all these women 61 this is number 61
these incredible women right here
they're rich as hell
i said to him i saw him two weeks so i
said also in north carolina but a long
ways away from here right it's a big
state
but i saw him two weeks i said how many
times have you been here they said
60 at the time i said it's because i've
seen them
i said your husbands have a problem with
that i think your husbands are with you
tonight the stand-up husbands please
stand up
look at these guys handsome very
handsome
good looking guys
how about the women standing up would
you stand up please
look at that
great people these are great people
these are great americans these are
really great
american people these are great american
people that we love
one of the most important issues in this
election
is the safety of the american family
the biden harris war on police would be
a catastrophe for our nation
just look at what the left has done in
democrat
run chicago portland new york city
oakland name any baltimore
did you hear what happened you know
obama's now campaigning
even though he refused to support biden
i mean he never
and then even after biden sort of semi
won
he sent my one he wouldn't do it he just
it took forever
but now he's campaigning for him and
somebody said sir
uh maybe this is a good restaurant
president obama is campaigning for
sleepy joe biden and i said ha
that's good news or bad news tell me are
you saying it's good or it's bad
well i guess it's bad no it's good there
was nobody that campaigned harder for
crooked hillary clinton
than obama right he was all over the
place
he said he will not be our president but
before that he said
he will not run he didn't know me
then i ran then he said he will not get
the nomination
then he got the nomination
and he said he will not be a president
then i won i think the only one
the only one more unhappy than crooked
hillary that night was
barack hussein obama
barack hussein obama you know when i say
that name i think of a man
who is an incredible man who's having
difficulty but there is nobody more
brave and he would talk a lot about
barack obama he would talk about obama
all the time
i wouldn't say in the most positive way
but with respect rush
limbaugh he's great
and you talk about a fighter he's
frightened he is a fighter you never saw
a fighter like russian
he got the presidential you know he got
up
our greatest our greatest
he got the presidential medal of freedom
which is the highest that in the
congressional medal of honor
and uh it was a great evening and
there's a fantastic wife and family but
russia is having a hard time
and i will tell you something he is
something special
try talking for years and years biggest
audience in radio history
try talking for three hours without
phone calls without you know it's easy
pick up a phone hey how you doing on
social security
he would just talk and talk and talk
biggest audience ever
sean hannity thinks one of the greats
ever in anything one of the greats
mark levine laura tucker has been
getting better and better all the time
the great blue dubs right great blue
dubs blue dobbs has been
blue great has been great now we have a
lot of we have a lot of great people and
we're getting more and more it's very
interesting
getting more but i just want to pay my
absolute respect he's in there fighting
and i'll tell you what
uh nobody can do it like him rush
limbaugh okay
biden and harris's anti-police rhetoric
is inciting riots and putting our police
in grand angel you know i watch this guy
today and he's talking about how it was
so comp
it wasn't ferguson st louis
baltimore right oakland they had things
going on that was
worse i mean you look at baltimore
remember that whole mass
but now it's like oh it was so wonderful
and then you look at the
h1n1 the joe crawls the opposite
the swine flu you look at that and you
say
well wait a minute that was handled so
badly and the person that was running
his whole thing
said this was handled so badly you have
no idea how badly it was run
and then they criticize us he says i
didn't close up
soon enough but he was two months late
and he was criticizing me for closing up
too soon
so you know it always gets me when
somebody's in office for 47 years
he could have done a lot how much he
said more
he could barely in office right but
all you have to do is you have to say
well why didn't you do it i always say
that
why didn't you do don't complain get it
done we get it done
nobody has done more in three and a half
years
but i will always stand because they
don't
they don't they want to distance shows
they want to disassociate themselves
i will always stand with the men and
women of law enforcement
biden is also pledging
mass amnesty and free federal health
care for illegal aliens and we all have
a heart
it will obliterate medicare and social
security with that
but we all have a heart the problem i
want to take care of everybody
the problem is our country will be
flooded with tens of millions of people
free health care free education
i always say for them it drives them
crazy everybody gets a free rolls royce
and then they say i am
misrepresenting they don't get a rolls
royce but no but
think of it free healthcare and i'll
always protect
you i will always protect your medicare
and your social security
it will never be protected
and i'm also proud that here in north
carolina
your medicare advantage premiums have
decreased because of us
because of good management by over 44
since i took office when you hear that
you don't hear that too often
go on healthcare we're providing
american families with affordable high
quality
personalized health care the washington
democrats
want bureaucrats calling the shots
rationing care
and deciding who gets treatment the
battle of the china virus we launched
the largest
mobilization since world war ii it's
incredible what we've done
and we've helped out a lot of governors
we've made a lot of really bad governors
look good
and we've made some good ones look great
and i can tell you got some bad ones and
we have some really good ones and i'll
someday tell you who it is
our early and aggressive action saved
more than two million lives i took rapid
action
to ban travel from china and europe and
biden opposed both remember
they're highly infected i said we got to
stop it we pioneered incredible
therapies
excuse me here i am here i am i don't
know what the hell
all i know i got it
and i have to look as president i can't
stay in the basement of the white house
i really can't i have to meet
i meet with families gold star families
i meet with so many people
heads of state i meet with all these
people sometimes i'll leave and i'll say
man that's dangerous
if you you know if you're really into i
start thinking i said you know i'm
meeting with so many people
but i can't stay in a basement or i
can't stay in a beautiful bedroom
in the white house where i say
hello world let me stay here for a year
i can't do that with the first lady
if i have to choose somebody i'll choose
the first lady
but oh
well i can't they do love melania
but i can't i can't just stay inside and
do that and it's risky and i caught it
and i didn't feel too good and i was
surrounded by doctors i've never seen so
many doctors in my life you know
i was always well taken care of but i've
never seen i mean every doctor from
every major
place in the world johns hopkins was
great
johns hopkins was really fantastic and
you know walter reed is unbelievable
but i had 12 doctors standing around my
bed and every one of them had a hand
on a different part of my body and i
didn't
i didn't like it but i didn't feel good
i didn't feel good
and they gave me what's called regeneron
which is antibodies very strong
antibodies and there is other eli lily
makes something i mean it's incredible
what they're doing by the way what
they're doing now is
incredible and i don't know maybe it was
great maybe it would maybe it would have
happened anyway but i woke up
the next morning and i felt like
superman
and i'm working to make the same
antibody treatment
that i received available to anybody
that needs it
free we're getting it approved
we're getting it we're signing what's
called emergency use declaration we're
getting it because it's so
new it's not even really approved it's
almost like right to try you know i got
right to try right
for people that are sick and they'd have
to travel to other parts of the world or
if they didn't have money they'd have to
go home and die even if we had something
that looked good but it wasn't approved
by the fda we cut those times way down
anyway
from i mean half we cut them in half but
still
has to be approved and we got right to
try don and that's where somebody
there's a drug that has potential and
somebody's dying
terminally ill and they couldn't do it
because they said well
supposing they die they're going to die
anyway and we got but still not easy
because the insurance companies had very
deep problems and the drug companies had
problems they didn't want them on the
list
a lot of different things and the
country had problems because the country
doesn't want to get sued by everybody
if it doesn't work out and so i have
them sign now we wrote up a very
sophisticated but simple agreement
that somebody taking any of the new
really incredible medicines we're the
greatest labs and doctors in the world
anybody taking it will sign away their
rights they're not going to sue anybody
and you know what's happened we have had
more success with right to try it's
incredible
it's really incredible it's a great
thing that's one of so many things we've
done we have done so many things
i could go on all night about the things
we've done but you'd start saying well
you know he's done a great job but let's
get the hell out of here harry
and we will have 100 million vaccine
doses before the end of this year
okay
and if you look cases in europe are
surging you know they don't talk about
that they're also europe europe europe
well sorry but they're surging i don't
want that to happen but cases in europe
are surging
biden's lockdown would reduce life
expectancy you know when you do these
lockdowns like you are suffering through
in north carolina
you have a governor depression
suicide drugs alcohol and many other
problems
and your kids want to go to school they
want to go they have to go to school
so i want to send a message tonight to
america's incredible moms
the moms are heroes they really are
they're heroes and they know better than
anyone
that their children do belong in school
and they want their children to go back
to school i will open your schools biden
will close your schools and you'll keep
them close i mean these people
it's like crazy what's going on i don't
get it
maybe maybe it will be right after you
know the election is going to end
hopefully we're going to win
and and then these governors will just
say oh
they'll go like this oh just open the
place up
oh the state's closed and so many i mean
you have five but see they think that's
going to give us worse numbers so here's
a number you have to watch out gdp
it's going to be announced two days
before the election november 3rd it's
going to be announced like on november
1st
just watch it i think it's going to sit
i don't know anything by the way
this is for the media no i don't have
any inside information
but the atlanta fed came out today and
they gave a number that's one of the
most incredible numbers anyone's ever
heard many times what the
all-time record would be they said gdp
will increase
in this third quarter by 35 percent 35
percent
people were hearing 20 people were
hearing 20 but here's the problem now if
it goes 25 or 30 they'll say
donald trump failed to meet i mean i
think the highest is probably eight
seven six eight something nine
but but they said they said they
predicted 35
so if it was 20 it would be incredible
that would be double triple what the
highest in history was
but this is a number that because we're
doing great but the democrats think by
keeping north carolina close and
pennsylvania we love pennsylvania closed
and by keeping michigan clubs this
governor that's always blaming everybody
for everything
by keeping except her husband by keeping
it's true by keeping michigan close and
all of this
that it'll affect the number well the
number is going to be great anyway
they got to open up california we got to
open up california
i see what's going on people are leaving
california they're leaving new york
because they can't take it
number one they have the basic problems
high taxes crime but on top of it they
can't even
open it's a very sad thing and they're
killing i don't know where they're
coming from i don't know what they're
doing
but they have to open these states up
and your governor has to open your state
and this is brilliant brilliant timing
what is this great timing because i just
see we're joined tonight
by your lieutenant governor dan forest
right
dan you better come up here come on
let's get this guy
where is that
come on dan look at him he's a handsome
guy don't worry he's locked in secret
service we'll get take your time
we're also joined by south carolina
lieutenant governor
pamela evan pamela where's palmer
thank you pamela wow so so young and so
strong and so smart good
you're doing a fantastic job say hello
to the governor
thank you thank you thank you penny
come up here dan
thank you mr president welcome to north
carolina another guest estonia welcome
mr president it's great to have you back
in the great state of north carolina you
can see with all these
tens of thousands of people here that
north carolina loves you
and north carolina is going to vote for
donald j trump one more time
in november
mr president we have a couple things in
common here our opponents are both stuck
in their basement for the last 200 days
they've uh they both have the same
philosophy
their their job is to destroy this
they have to build up we both come from
a business background mr president and
i'm going to work with you to make north
carolina great again and we're going to
work to make
america great again
so donald j trump president trump has
done more for the united states of
america in the last
46 months than joe biden has done in the
last 46 years
we don't need a we don't need a
do-nothing president in america
we need a president that gets things
done here in north carolina
we have a do-nothing governor for four
years we have a governor who's done
absolutely nothing except for shut our
state down shut our schools down
close our economy down and destroy
one of the greatest economies the united
states of america has ever seen
so my friends join with me over the next
13 days
to vote republican vote donald j trump
and vote dan forrest for governor
god bless you
thank you dan thank you
thank you dan he'll be a great governor
hey dan you're making a lot of progress
i see the polls are very close
then they're getting a little bit
nervous they're getting a little nervous
about you
a friend of mine from the beginning
she's always been with me and just a
fantastic woman
virginia fox congresswoman
she walks into a room and those
congressmen they
shake and they quit right that's true
another friend of mine who uh we were
involved with right at the beginning he
showed incredible courage and
stamina the race was a tough race he's
got another one coming up now and i hope
everybody's going to be with him
he's turned out to be a great
congressman dan bishop
there dan bishop
thank you dan great job a lot of courage
and also a warrior friend really helps
out whenever we need it he's there
ted budd ted
great congress thank you thank you ted
thank you north carolina gop chair
michael watley hi michael
and we're doing well ah that's good
michael we're going to win the state i
would think
oh i'll tell you you know those votes
are all sort of coming in and some
aren't coming in like they thought they
went a little bit
they're going a little crazy michael
they're a little bit concerned about
what's happening aren't they
not only here a lot of other states too
press
just refuses to report it but eventually
they have to
because you know at some point you win
and then they say okay remember last
time right four years ago
remember the hand of king john king he
was sort of like
i haven't seen him lately did he get
fired or something
i think one of their lawyers just got
fired
i just got fired for a good reason
well he hasn't been too nice to us let's
face it that was a strange deal going
on no but remember the uh remember four
years ago the
thing his hands looked very brave oh
this is going to be very old it's going
to be over very quick
and about four hours later yeah the hand
was
the hand started to shake
and then he said i can't believe what's
happening but we could believe it we
know it and we know what's happening
again
we know what's happening again except
more so
this is now happening again michael
except more so you were there is this
more than
four years ago yeah no there's more
enthusiasm
there's more enthusiasts there's more
support
no this is even more so i think michael
you better win michael i will fire you
so fast
and two friends of mine i'll tell you
what these people my wife called she
said
i just have to come over she was in new
york and she came in
she said you have to see and she brought
a clip she said you have to see this
these two people are great
they're great this is four years ago it
was diamond and silk
no it's true first lady came in she said
you got to take a look at this being and
she pressed i said that's amazing they
are great
thank you very much right from the
beginning right
you understood long before a lot of
other people you understood you got
it they're also doing really well for
themselves and i'm happy i said go out
and do well
right thank you thank you great honor
thank you great people
thanks also to your senator tom tillis
whose opponent had an unexpected problem
times two
now tom's a good guy tom's been with us
he's been uh
working hard he's respected very much in
washington he's really a good
he's really a good senator really a good
senator
and he's been he's been strong so i hope
he gets in i hope you guys can
go out and get him in he's terrific but
he really did you know he had uh
hit little duck but we wouldn't guard
luck it's uh
you know it's a unfortunate situation in
many ways so we'll see how it all turns
out but it's a close race going to be a
tough race
but uh our race doesn't look like it's
going to be as close
our race looks like it's
and with us as well are members of the
incredible
lumbee
where are they oh look at you guys wow
wow that's a good looking group of
people
columbia thank you very much for being
here we appreciate it and
we're working with you and you have a
great congressman and dan you know that
right
right dan i'll tell you you're lucky you
have to end
he's a big supporter thank you very much
thank you everybody
as you know the lumbee tribe has been
fighting for
federal recognition for more than a
century that's all
well you're moving faster than a lot of
people that's a long time
when i am re-elected we'll work with
congress and we'll work with dan and
we'll work with all of them on the
lumbee recognition act and we'll get it
done
and i notice you do have great support
within the state you have dan but you
have great support within the state so
that's great we'll work on that very
strongly
thank you thank you under my
administration we built the greatest
economy in the history of the world
and now we are doing it again
in my first three years we increased
family income
over six thousand dollars and much more
when you include energy because you know
these people want to wipe out your
energy we're energy independent
they want to wipe it out whoever thought
you'd be paying two dollars for gasoline
sometimes less
you know that's like that's like a big
tax cut
that's more than five times the gains in
all eight years
under the obama administration
think of that in three years versus
eight years
medium income range and reached
wow sixty nine thousand dollars that's
good that's good that's an all-time
that's an all-time high income for
black americans grew nine times
think of that it grew nine times
more under my leadership
than under biden and obama nine
times more much shorter period of time
african-american unemployment
hispanic american unemployment and
asian-american unemployment all reached
their lowest levels
in the history of our country
women's unemployment reached the lowest
rate in more than 70 years
we lifted nearly 7 million americans out
of poverty
including nearly 1.2 million african
americans lifted out of poverty
look at that nobody's done this he's a
world record
when the virus hit we experienced the
smallest contraction of
any major country anywhere in the world
and we also are now witnessing by far
the fastest recovery we're recovering
faster than anything
and you'll see what that number is let's
see what it is
i don't know 35 but it's going to be a
great number since april we created a
record 11.4 million jobs never done that
before
under biden it took 30 months to recover
more than half of the jobs lost in the
crisis
we did it in five months think of that
we've spent the last four years
reversing the damage
joe biden inflicted over the last 47
years he supported
nafta the worst trade deal ever made
tpp would have been the worst trade deal
ever made would have been even worse but
i didn't let it go through
and china's entry into the world trade
organization
one of the worst things ever to happen
to this country
he betrayed quite honestly the american
worker that's what he did
and he always has he always has now he
said
we have to protect america we have to
protect
we have to hire he says we have to hire
he copied me we have to hire american he
says
i said he copied me get a new phrase
he's not doing anything he didn't do it
for years and forget the 47.
you know it wasn't like they were out
long right
he didn't do any of this stuff when they
were there he also voted
for the war in iraq terrible decision
for decades our politicians spent
trillions and trillions of dollars
rebuilding foreign nations fighting
foreign wars
and defending foreign borders but now we
are finally protecting our nation
rebuilding our cities and we are
bringing our
jobs our factories and our troops back
home to the usa where they belong
and i'm also taking care of north
carolina tobacco growers is that okay
yes north carolina tobacco
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure border in u.s history by far
my opponent's insane immigration plan
would be a nightmare for north carolina
families he would eliminate u.s borders
by implementing nationwide catch and
release we end the catch and release
that's when you catch somebody could be
a murderer it could be a rapist could be
a criminal of some kind
and you let them free and say excuse me
come back in four years we're going to
give you a trial nobody ever comes back
who would come back only a very stupid
person would come back
so it's catch and release i ended that
you think that was easy to end that it
was not easy
it was not easy sounds easy but it was
it's ended
and he wants to make every community
into a sanctuary city for violent
criminals no thank you
the biden harris plan and you've had a
lot of problems with your sanctuary
cities and you've had a lot of crime
because of your
and a lot of death with your sanctuary
cities and city
the biden harris plan would also
increase refugees
700 from the most dangerous places in
the world
that was done with crazy bernie right
that was the manifesto i called the
manifesto
they agreed to the 700 increase they
pledged to terminate
all national security travel bans which
i got i got a travel ban
remember they said you'd never get it
approved i got it approved and now if
somebody hates us if they hate us from a
different part of the world we say i'm
sorry
you cannot come in that makes sense
doesn't it
they'll open the floodgates to radical
islamic terrorism
the beheading that took place in france
just
a few days ago is a horrifying reminder
that we have to be vigilant and i sent
our regards and our
sympathies to france and to their
president
macron who's a terrific guy he's working
very hard
i'm keeping the terrorists jihadist and
violent extremists
the hell out of our country if that's
okay with you
and i will never say it because it's not
good to say it and i'm knocking on nice
beautiful wood because i can tell it's
ours because it's
they spend a lot of money on building
these things
but you haven't seen too much happening
on that front have you huh you notice
okay well keep your eyes hey keep your
eyes open okay keep your eyes open
because they'd love to do something just
keep your eyes open
but there's a reason for things not
happening also
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s
military
and as you all know defense spending in
north carolina has soared
made in the usa all made in the usa
and for our great veterans we passed va
choice and va accountability nobody
thought that was ever gonna happen
we killed the leader of isis al baghdadi
and we took out the mass murder of
american troops
salamani is dead
i went through from the last
administration's disastrous iran nuclear
deal
one how about this 150 billion dollars
for
nothing and don't forget 1.8 billion in
cash many airplanes loaded up with cash
i recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
52 years they worked on that we got it
done in two hours
52 years and instead of never ending
wars we are forging peace in the middle
east without blood all over the sand
just signed up another country today
iran doesn't want to let me win
china doesn't want to let me win they
want me to be defeated so badly
and the swamp doesn't want to let me win
because i am fighting for you i'm
fighting for you
the first call i'll get after we win the
first call i'll get will be from iran
saying let's make a deal because you
talk about an economy their economy gdp
down 27
nobody's ever even heard of it a vote
for republicans is a vote for safe
communities great jobs
and a limitless future for all americans
so in conclusion
we're all about the american dream you
know we're about the american dream
abraham lincoln was a republican we have
to say that
honestly over the next four years we
will make america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world and we will end
our reliance on china
once and for all it's already happening
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults or law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
second amendment
and remember joe biden is going to take
away your second amendment
you're going to take it away don't even
think about it
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten our cities and we will keep
america
out of these ridiculous absolutely crazy
foreign wars we will do it countries
you've never even heard of
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength that's what we have right now
and the equipment that we built is the
greatest anywhere in the world
russia china north korea everybody
we are the envy nobody has equipment
like us
missiles rockets tanks
submarines ships
fighter jets beautiful beautiful
the best stuff anywhere in the world
hydrosonic missiles
seven times faster than anything else
seven times they go rather quickly
we've totally redone our nuclear and
hope to god
all of it hope to god we never have to
use any of it
but you know because it's now redone you
know remember i got here in a highly
overrated general
said sir we have no ammunition i said
that should never happen to a president
again
but hope to god this equipment never has
to be used but nobody has it like us
and you know the reason it may never be
used is because we have it if we didn't
have it
we may have very big problems we could
have had very big problems we got it
done
made in the usa we will end surprise
medical billing
require price transparency already done
already signed kicks in on january 1st
that's a big thing that's going to be
bigger
price please remember price transparency
bigger than healthcare when you see this
a lot of people aren't too happy with
what i did there
further reduce the cost of prescription
drugs favorite nations we're going to
get the lowest in the world
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
always america will land the first woman
on the moon and the united states will
be the first nation to land an astronaut
on mars
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
schools
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america now you
have a president who is standing up for
america
and standing up for the great people of
north carolina standing up for north
carolina
but we have the most important election
in our history so get your friends
get your family get your neighbors get
your co-workers get your boss rip them
out of the seat
and get out and vote
gotta get out of there
from asheville we'll be there soon to
charlotte
from wilmington to raleigh and from
greensboro to right here in gastonia
we stand on the shoulders of red-blooded
american patriots
who poured out their hearts sweat and
soul to secure
our liberty and defend our freedom
our brave american ancestors crossed the
oceans
blazed the trail settled the continent
tamed the wilderness dug out the panama
canal
laid down the railroads raised up the
great skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and made america the single greatest
nation
in the history of the world and you
haven't seen
anything yet
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power
to you the american people that's what
happened four years ago
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
we are one movement one people
one family and one glorious nation under
god
and together with the incredible people
of north carolina
we have made america powerful again our
military
we have made america wealthy again
our stock market your 401ks
your 401ks are booming
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you north carolina go
out and vote
thank you go and vote thank you very
much
is
but you've got
uh
oh
oh
walk up the street
is
pick yourself up
is
oh my god
everybody
baby
is
bye